salut aujourd'hui je vous fais cette
vidéo depuis ma chambre d'hôtel parce
que je suis en tournée à narbonne juste
avant de commencer cette vidéo pour info
j'ai beaucoup de chance grâce à vous je
suis complet de plus en plus en avance
donc si jamais vous voulez venir me voir
à montauban à bordeaux à strasbourg à
sénas à mulhouse et dans d'autres villes
vous pouvez cliquer sur le lien que dans
la description petite info si vous êtes
de bretagne des pays de la loire ou de
vendée rajouter mois sur les réseaux
sociaux je peux être un truc à vous dire
en a pris aujourd'hui je voulais essayer
quelque chose sur vous quelque chose que
j'ai en tête depuis un moment un
interactions l'idée c'est de vous
surprendre peut-être c'est parti à y
avoir un mélange entre le rationnel la
voyance le mentalisme une sorte de
triptyque comme ça faut pas faire ce
geste là je crois écrivez sur un bout de
papier ou visualiser dans votre esprit
votre année de naissance à l'envers de
la fin vers le début de mois je suis né
en 1982 ça fait 2891 si vous êtes né en
2003 ça fait 3000 2 prenez le temps de
visualiser pour pas vous tromper votre
année de naissance à l'envers je vais
maintenant vous demander une petite
soustraction très simple vous pouvez le
faire avec une calculatrice ou sur le
papier mais ne vous trompez pas vous
allez soustraire de votre année de
naissance votre année naissance à
l'envers où c'est un choix c'est votre
liberté votre année de naissance à
l'envers - votre année de naissance ce
un petit peu dans l'ordre que vous
voulez régulièrement lors de cette vidéo
je vais être obligé de dire des formules
magiques celle ci est très très simple
mais un peu dur à prononcer est alors
facile alors qu'augmentaient swiss fait
bizarre un peu sain dans les oreilles
passons à la phase de numérologie vous à
les additionner tous les chiffres en
sang
si vous avez un signe négatif vous
l'oubliez si votre résultat final c'est
moins 2891 ça fait 2 et 8 10 et 9 19 et
1 26 votes résultat final c'est 3045
vous faites 3 + 4 7 + 5 12 pendant que
vous faites cette petite numérologie je
vais en profiter pour dire la deuxième
formule magique
cette deuxième formule magique c'est
simple c'est eux jugent hall
vous avez compris eux qui ge hall en
fait une version plus longue de eux qui
geôles au melon isoler les ouvrages à
anosy vie moureaux vous avez un résultat
final en tête il est issu de votre date
de naissance et de la numérologie que
vous allez dans le tableau suivant
le mot qui est associé à votre résultat
vous voici le tableau avec toutes ces
possibilités vous lisez vous retenez
évidemment le mot qui est associé à
votre résultat numérologique peut à
peine de faire poser je veux pas faire
durer ce moment là vous devez déjà avoir
votre mot en tête maintenant avant
dernière formule magique
les deux hommes c'est une couche fine et
je crois que c'est là c'est le plus
compliqué et pour terminer vous demander
de prendre la dernière lettre de votre
mot et de cette dernière lettre
d'imaginer un mot en rapport avec votre
mot de départ
je m'explique un peu plus clairement un
exemple très concret si votre mot c'est
mr je sais qu'il n'existait pas dans le
tableau celui-là donc si votre mot c'est
mr m er la dernière lettre c'est le r
est un mot qui commencerait par cette
lettre en rapport avec le mot mère ça
pourrait être ado ça pourrait être
requins je vous laisse donc quelques
secondes pour prendre la dernière l'aide
de votre mot et d'imaginer un mot en
relation avec votre mode de départ qui
commence par 7 et vous me dites dans les
commentaires quand vous êtes prêt pour
que je continue
non par contre vous pouvez me dire dans
les commentaires tels mots vous avez
actuellement en tête ça ne changera rien
puisque la vidéo est déjà fait
dès que vous avez votre mot vous
l'écrivez tout de suite j'imagine que ça
doit être bon alors je vais pas révéler
le mot exactement mais je pense pouvoir
révéler le thème de votre mot grâce à la
dernière formule tu pas si évidente non
plus et qui se dit fut les cheveux du
votre aîné jamie je pense que le thème
de votre nouveau mot est en rapport avec
les équations avec l'esprit peut-être
même avec le monde des énigmes je crois
que c'est quelque chose comme ça à temps
je sais que c'est pas très très bluffant
parce que c'est ça aussi à maisdon
d'antalis me permettre de dire que de
l'autre côté de l'écran vous êtes en
train de vous dire oui moi ça va pas non
plus se ça mais c'est pas exactement ce
à quoi
mais peut-être qu'il y avait une
deuxième chose de caché dans cette vidéo
peut-être que derrière les formules
magiques il y avait une deuxième chose
ça vous dit qu'on se refasse tout mais à
l'envers
pensez aux mots que vous aviez choisi le
départ peut imaginer que tout était
prévu depuis le début
mais ça lui sinon ça voudrait dire que
je connaissais votre mot depuis le début
au premier visionnage vous allez choisir
le mot logique de mon look ou sanitaire
logique yeux est complètement logique
eux
si vous êtes encore là laissé un gros
like
j'espère que cette idée vous aura plu si
elle fait des émules
je m'amuserai à écrire d'autres vidéos
comme ça qui sont des vidéos un petit
peu de divertissement logique
ça m'a pris pas mal de temps après c'est
alors je me fixe et une barre si on
dépasse je sais pas moi les 25000 light
par exemple je ressortir une vidéo dans
le même style c'est une motivation pour
moi aussi n'oubliez pas que parfois
traîne des surprises dans la description
de la vidéo merci d'avoir regardé ça
vous pouvez vous abonner comme
d'habitude elle rendez vous très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]